Just because it's a woman entering a child's life,
that shit is really fucking weird, too.
Flip those rules.
Flip that shit.
It's a woman who's a single mother.
She meets a guy on the internet.
She doesn't have any place to stay for her and her children,
so she just moves in with this guy.
And he is very happy to step up as stepdad
and immediately help change diapers,
bathe, drive them to and from school,
get all invested in their life. After knowing each other for weeks,
what would we say to that fucking mother, huh?
Why it's not okay when? For dads?
And those women who do it are fucking psychotic.
Women can abuse children.
Women can assault children.
Why are we just so accepting
when these dudes start dating some woman from god fucking knows where?
That this woman is willing
to have this man that she barely knows and his children in her house?
And then when the mother says something,
she's the fucking lunatic.
I'm so sorry. What?
No,
no.